this is very very interesting
many republicans have been demanding
smaller
packages from democrats as we talked
about yesterday
gen saki regularly reminded of the fact
that all these different republicans say
biden's package is too big they need a
smaller
package mitt romney is doing something
very interesting mitt romney is a
republican senator
he has a proposal to provide three
thousand dollars per child to millions
of american families and this would be
a form of bipartisan support for joe
biden's
um covid relief plan which includes
expanding
child benefits now it's a slightly
different
framework romney would give forty two
hundred dollars per year per child
up to age six that goes down to three
thousand dollars per year per child for
age six to 17
and how that would interact with some of
these other
elements is in the details that that we
are still
learning about but what is very
interesting about this
is that one of the reasons that mitt
romney
and maybe some other republicans are
interested in this
is that they think if you give these
bigger
payments uh to people they will be
less likely to uh file
uh or no i'm sorry let me go backwards
uh republicans believe that
giving payments would discourage parents
from finding jobs and this is their
concern with what
mitt romney and also with what joe biden
are proposing
this is this very old trope that we hear
from the right
which is predicated on the idea that
everybody's lazy
and nobody has any drive or motivation
and people just want to figure out how
to not work at all
most people you know there's an
evolutionary
thing to this and when we i've read some
very interesting articles about
you know people who feel unfulfilled and
all these different things
there are practical reasons for that
people seeking meaning and fulfillment
but there may also be an evolutionary
reason which is when you were
fulfilled human advancement potentially
stopped when you were satisfied
you stopped trying to improve your
circumstances and those of
your children and their children and so
on so there may even be an evolutionary
basis for this but
most people want to do something most
people want meaning yes
there are some people who for a variety
of different reasons
want the easiest path out if i can just
sit at home and not work and collect
money that's fine
most people don't want that most people
want
one job that pays well so that they can
have some meaning coming from employment
and also have the financial wherewithal
um to be able to raise kids put food on
the table for family
participate in life in other ways and
this republican idea that if you do this
it always assumes the worst about
people's intentions and the worst about
humanity and that's really how these
republicans see people but i'm glad to
see mitt romney proposing
um proposing an alternative to this now
this is going to be the the the way that
romney's idea would be integrated is
that mitt romney
wants it to be an amendment to the
democratic budget resolution
and uh it looks as though a budget
wrestle resolution budget reconciliation
is increasingly likely to be
the way that this coveted relief bill is
going to be passed and as i've said
before
the fact that democrats can pass this
without
any republican involvement to me signals
the time for so-called negotiation with
republicans is over
but i don't believe every republican
will vote against it i believe that
there are
republicans that either for personal
political convictions
or because of their their realization
that coveted relief is popular with
their constituents
some republicans are going to vote for
this and uh put
call them on their bluff right see if
they actually
are all going to vote against the 1.9
trillion dollar package if that's what
democrat democrats go forward with i
don't believe that they will
and in particular now with mitt romney
jumping in which
makes this listen i always thought it
was naive to think you're going to get
this big bipartisan
coveted relief bill when the party of
republicans is the party of obstruction
but merely mitt romney saying here's an
idea and then i'm in favor of it
it makes it technically bipartisan even
if nobody else comes on board so i think
these are very very interesting
developments and to be very clear
i know there are people who keep writing
to me saying davey boy
why aren't you calling out biden for the
fact that he said 2000 and now it's 1400
and why aren't you calling out biden for
the fact that he said the checks would
go out right away and they haven't i
have called them out
i called them out in just about every
segment i've done including on
yesterday's show
uh joe biden has already not done what
he promised which is he said it would be
two thousand dollars
not to not 1400 to get to a total of
2000 with the last stimulus joe biden
said two thousand dollar checks
now they're talking about 1400 that's
already a problem
joe biden also said if democrats win the
two seats in georgia
checks go out right away well it's
already uh february
i understand this takes a little bit of
time but it's time to move forward it's
time to do it with budget reconciliation
whether or not republicans
want to be involved and i hope i mean
listen if mitt romney proposing even
more money for children is the way to
make it bipartisan and get more
republicans
to support it great if not it's time for
democrats to get it done by themselves
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there is a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video